welcome back to new rock stars debrief
the show where we go into all the
stories that you might have missed this
week in the world of nerd I'm Erik Voss
and joining me today are Philip Malina
hello is thanks Jay
that's one of them and Sam basher you're
gonna save it myself Philip back to you
too Erik oh I'm at home now today we're
talking about a major Avengers in game
theory some Captain Marvel news and
Howard the Duck series of coming out
whoo this is an exciting week we're
talking about you know you got to hook
them with the weird right that's you
know now you're watching nice Howard Oh
Howard oh and by the way you can help
the audio version this episode some of
you may be listening to the podcast
version of this
yeah how's that going so far hopefully
you're listening on the Himalaya app you
can also post on the Apple podcast app
wherever you get your podcast in LA
obviously it is very important that you
have your podcast situation down because
we get a lot of time stuck in our cars
schedule we have 10 moments so hopefully
your may be listening to this during
your commute we don't mind if you're
only half listening and half driving now
ful fully Drive I Drive slowly drive
your Fulton and fully listen honestly
even if the traffic so we are used to
doing that ourselves so I hope you're
doing it too let's hope you enjoy okay
so here's what we've heard this week
there's a big of interest in game theory
going around and it's pretty strong
oilerie so if you don't want to know
anything about of interest in game you
should have stopped listening or
watching play now so so bounce out and
then come back to so one person is
running out of the shower but that's
enough time for spoiler shower boy no
damping here we go so there was a Lego
leak and as we've said before guys the
answers are in the toys here right the
toys have all kinds of weird stuff and
fain it
there's an even saying it since Legos
existed all throughout the lego movie
you ruined that movie so here's what it
shows there's a picture of the Avengers
confronting the Chitauri
Chitauri story if you don't remember
they're the hive mind mercenary army
that Thanos gave to Loki to invade earth
with and that's what they were
fighting in the Battle of New York and
we haven't seen the Chitauri since then
the Chitauri showed up in a flashback
and Avengers infinity war when they were
conquering gomorrah's planet but this is
a group that he worked with and it all
ended with the Battle of New York yeah
Harry was dead he had one but it was all
covered up by a face he was the one that
was messing with nebula it was like but
they never showed the face because they
didn't want to show those horse face
people and these are also the ones those
dopes as like sine waves that they ride
now people hold out yeah people have
speculated for a while that we may have
been revisiting the Battle of New York
and Avengers in a game I know we made a
cup right back it's possibly gonna have
time travel it's not even necessarily
news that it could go back to the Battle
of New York right we've seen some
pictures maybe that look like there
Reese agent but with this Lego said it's
like another form of confirmation we're
putting the pieces together that oh this
is we're really going what exactly is
the theory well here's a theory that
people are starting to buzz about now if
the Avengers could get back to the
Battle of New York through through
time-travel there's a lot of different
ways time travel could be feasible
either through the time stone through
time for testing backwards quantum realm
yeah you know there's all kinds of ways
that we talked about but if they are
able to get back there remember there
was that wormhole that led in the
Chitauri that the space still oriented
it was a rift through space-time or ice
through space is a space stone if they
could go through that wormhole the way
Iron Man briefly did to throw the nuke
at the Chitauri army what if they were
able to go through that wormhole and
then go confront fan o's before he's
able to get all the Infinity stones
fight him on his turf maybe maybe Hitler
before he grows up exactly before he's
prepared to to fight all of them it's
kind of cheating that's what I'm travels
the form of cheating yeah let's get him
before he knows that like we know
everything about him and his whole plan
yeah I mean it's really I mean Thanos is
kind of an almighty deity figure at this
point the man Titan he has feasibly
conceivably he might already know that
they're gonna be doing this because the
the six stones should give him almost at
nipa tense
maybe I could be something that uh ha
like he's going so you'd have to stop
him to stop them before they travel the
time but let's say they do it here's
what's really interesting they
successfully stopped him
and that's gotta have ripple effects
throughout like all of phase three oh
right all the things that Thanos has
done I feel like we should kind of go
into those right okay so looking back at
a timeline what has happened since the
Battle of New York
right so the Avengers have gotten hold
of the mind stone at what its what
caused all the drama and age of ultron
animated vision that's what Ultron was
trying to get his hands on we didn't
know at that point that it was the mine
stone that was established after the
fact after the Battle of New York so if
they're able to interfere with that
maybe Thanos maybe the first stone he
gets his hands on on his quest is the
mine stone rather than getting the the
power stone I believe was the first one
that he got in Avengers infinity war the
guardians the guy right yeah right but
he already had the one he gave to Loki
right he did have that one but then he
lost it through the internet so so just
I guess it depends on like how badly he
stopped right then cuz he would have
already had it I guess look he would
have it so we said Power Stone right so
do we oh do we get original group back
oh the original original Groot
yeah or something like that I'm waiting
for super sized super-powered Groot
which would be kind of fun as well but I
wouldn't mind getting original group
back he's my favorite so far you know
who else are we I think we definitely
get back as the collector oh yeah
because they a knows is the collector
dead we don't know what his fate is he
there's a big Drive in his life implied
that they he killed like a planet's
worth of people to go get that stuff
right you know where's enormous right
yeah but you see the collector there but
then he's only part of the projection of
the reality stone so we don't see where
he went that was all part of the
projection part of the trick to lure in
Gamora in the other guimard guardians
became already someone else Guardians
why the good mordant's that's another
person
yeah for sure oh yeah good point you
know you mentioned phase 3 Phillip
there's this long like running theory
that that whole weird time jump in
spider-man homecoming what's not a
mistake
remember it's spider-man homecoming we
saw the Battle of New York and then it
said eight years later which would be
impossible because the Battle of New
York was set either in 2011 or something
like 20
well should have been six years later no
less than six years or no more than six
years later so but some people are
thinking that that was intentional and
there's gonna be some kind of timeline
meddling in Avengers endgame that retro
actively fixes that like as Doctor
Strange is like reuniting the timeline
he like drops two years back to the
world yeah yeah I feel like yeah we
could we could make that work right now
I think that might be a little bit of
garbage but I feel like you could make
that work I don't know about like
totally doing the time-travel band-aid
Oh for like fixing this kind of mess I
like the idea of getting the time-travel
Sheena against and then having to fix
them that's always kind of fun and
stories go back to the future do stop
and what if got it replaying events yeah
spoiled that for you sorry about that
existence the Back to the Future - there
you go but I don't know it's just it
feels like the repercussions kind of get
like way too like lofty it's like what
if we can do this couldn't we just like
get everybody back forever and ever
couldn't both war machine actors be back
and then yes I got you look like me but
you know we're both big fans of the idea
of like they just have to go to a
different universe and let half the
people which is always be dead and in
that original one this actually doesn't
necessarily negate that because this
version of time-travel is if we're
acting like it's the kind where it's
like oh they can go back and change time
and then it'll have ripple effect of
repercussions in the future but there
are theories of time travel where it's
like great you created a new branch yes
and so this branch you guys fixed it and
it's never gonna happen and the original
branch is still out there and they're
still half the universe dead yeah yeah
no matter what it is hopefully it's
harder for the Avengers time-travel
shouldn't make things easier whatever
new technology they have or new cosmic
influence they have to change the
timeline whether it's going through the
multiverse or going back in time
whatever complicated thing you want to
do memory version of time-travel unstuck
in time should make things way harder
for them like this it should be even
more challenging for the Avengers an
endgame otherwise it's less interesting
otherwise the stakes feel lower in a way
it feels too easy okay and I just got
something from our producer by the way
she held up a very large card that a
very interesting point on it Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel was
only brought back into the fold via the
pager at the end of infinity war yeah if
the pager doesn't happen how does
Captain Marvel get back into the fold
right yeah she needs to be part of this
somehow
whatever the new timeline is said I mean
we are also are forgetting time-travel
is something that supposedly is one of
Captain Marvel's abilities according to
a Sam Jackson leak in an interview keep
saying stuff that doesn't make any sense
yeah yeah so this would need to be a
version of the time-travel that is on a
different timeline rather than a fixed
loop because if it negates her entrance
into this world and yeah I want to
discredit what he says but then he did
spoil Red Skull yeah he's got a track
record for his spoilers being accurate
uh well I guess let us know what you
guys think about this theory it's a
pretty of all the theories you've had
it's probably one of the most possible
interesting for sure it's definitely
interested it would explain a lot of
things and still also be very fun very
much future - looks not what you guys
think yeah we weekly trivia question as
always we die in Airport it's a bear
calling for his mother is there a bear
mother in this maze so here's the
question as always we ask this question
will reveal the answer at the end and
the loser will have to draw some from
the gift of shame but our question for
this week which comic book superhero was
originally created by a major toy
company okay all of our answers are here
in the bucket I say or they give up
shame box didn't touch it put my hands
on it it didn't touch it it's Travis
made it for us we're gonna put it back
together I think it's fine yeah like oh
okay no it's fine because I didn't touch
it
okay so Philip you were kind of alluding
some news that we want to get to in a
second about Captain Marvel but first we
want to shout out our friends over at
Ridge wallets thanks to rich for
sponsoring this episode guys if you find
that your wallet gets bulky and just
kind of stupid and you especially sit on
it originally I have to pull this out of
my seat every time I see I think that's
what I call my butt yeah
out of my back pocket every week when we
do this show because it makes me likes
it too high on one side your stance or
gives you scoliosis yeah yeah well this
is why you should think about getting a
Ridge wallet I did you did look at look
at this a Ridge is a minimalist front
pocket wallet you know I've been
watching a lot of that Marie Kondo show
and she's been you know spark and joy
and she's been thinking a lot about how
much stuff that I have and this wallet
has definitely helped I know about you
guys is helping me streamline what I
carry around with you just carry like
the cards that you need I'm not gonna
show you guys my license and information
but you carry that and your cash and you
push it out and it's your sleeve you
need yeah and it doesn't make a big like
bulge on the side yeah no bulges in your
pants yeah bulge in sight yeah
oh it's also check that it's like modern
it's cool-looking it's kind of Future II
it's it can be made out of titanium or
carbon fiber or aluminum and it's guys
its RFID blocking which is great so
you're not gonna have anybody really
steal your credit card information or
you you just hang out a lot and it's
lifetime guaranteed it's the last wallet
you ever need to buy really cuz you know
it's lifetime guarantee that's creating
a lifetime okay so here's the deal
get 10% off today guys with free
worldwide shipping I have to do is go to
rich wallet comm slash new rock stars
again that's Ridge wallet comm slash new
rock stars can use our promo code of new
rock stars or click on the link in the
description of this episode thanks so
much to a draw up for sponsoring us they
make it so we can do this show hey your
favorite pictures of you with your Ridge
wallet look way cooler earlier your time
I kept Marvel being the one that would
stuff to be pulled in some way i7
picture deal guys hear about this
okay brie Larson has signed a seven
picture that's what these call movies
back in the day right before they moved
to the top yeah now a seven picture deal
to continue playing Captain Marvel 7
movies so I thought it'd be fun to try
to get
what seven movies doesn't say that three
of them are probably freebies right I'm
gonna say Captain Marvel and then
endgame and then I'm slightly going on
eliminating Captain Marvel - yeah what
sue me dishes yeah but there are a bunch
of other phase four movies that it could
be there's you know far from home the
Black Widow yeah they put out a name
that is Panther to Doctor Strange - yeah
so it could be any of those could be a
different one yeah how do you think well
this is it seven picture deals Shannon
that means she's play the star of the
face like Chris Hemsworth has appeared
in a total of seven MC movies recent
three he said three Thor movies three
Avengers movies and then a fourth
Avengers endgame yeah so that's seven
he's not even in seven eight so they're
already committing to seven four brie
Larson so yeah I think they're assuming
there's gonna be a Captain Marvel
trilogy which i think is a big
assumption well here's the thing it's
it's the Iron Man trilogy replacement as
my I guess what does this mean captain
Marvel's being set up to be the Ilia
Iron Man the team yeah Brian if like
thinking about pondering for like the
past couple months which is it seems
like a good it seems like a good get
also just like thinking about like for
her sequel since its Creed based and
you're talking about like aliens have
invaded earth honestly and I know people
are gonna say poopoo in the in the chat
or in the podcast notes in humans
they're they directly connected she has
a lot to do with the Inhumans and I know
Marvel tried real hard to make huh do it
over do it over they wanted mutants
wrote bad but now they got mutant so now
you play with a few of the Inhumans yeah
this could mean a Secret Wars movie to
the Russos have said after in game the
movie that they would most want to do is
a Secret Wars movie which brings in the
scroll which could potentially bring in
Captain Marvel yeah they could also end
up in some sort of like I don't know
battle with an eternal or something like
say there's time travel and endgame and
then at the end it's like well we can't
do that without consequences and now you
know Chronos or someone like is like
gonna be set up as this new villain and
then she kind of is doing you know her
space spite and not so much ground level
can I say this might be a bit premature
to seven movies seven movies is insane
that's like assuming that not just
Captain Marvel as a movie will do well
but that brie Larson will be the reason
she can't do any other movie she can
only do these seven movies yeah yeah
yeah it's a long time that's gonna be
her twenties yeah I mean I know it's
tomorrow we might not get as successful
as Black Panther was they aren't already
committing to a black panther yeah they
come in to do a second one which I don't
think has been officially announced you
crazy they signed her just seven
pictures and the first one's not out yet
yeah yeah it could be a bomb I don't
think it'll be a bomb it sounds like
there's a lot of positive vibes coming
I'm excited for this movie I think it'll
be great we'll say it's not getting as
much like excitement but neither did
like Doctor Strange before it came out
and that one did fine
I think it's cuz they put it so close to
endgame you know mean like I think
everyone is like me and hang Games
coming up and we stock after marble
billboards or like whoops yeah this
might be a sign to investors to like
they want to show after endgame don't
worry some people may be dying off but
we have a future in store we decided
solutions do star State of the Union of
Marvel right set up phase four just kind
of be like I would Capitan they went
through like their roster yeah the
roster why aren't they showing us the
roster yet right I feel like for Phase
three we know maybe it's because after
they did it right before age of Ultron
people look well yes we know these
characters you know they do time travel
but they turn back into kids and then
all the movies are adventures kids baby
in the comics she's led to pretty
popular teams The Ultimates which is
your ultimate version of the Avengers
which when it was kind of like yeah your
universe reshuffling storyline they they
popped up with the Avengers and they
were like you're more like kind of
grittier a super team and they're like
the crazy Opie heroes that are flying
around space they don't need a helmet
that's how cool they are also she leads
alpha flight which has now been kind of
relegated to planetary protection from
space and giant space station I've been
waiting for a giant Space Station one of
these movies like a Justice League
Watchtower kind of I would let that's
like Marvel's current answer to that and
I'm a
big fan of that more space adventures
more cool space tech I'm on board with
that you you just you just want more
Legos like glass pieces you can peek
inside well your child I am Sam child
confirmed well yeah
child Lee tell us about what you've
heard this week about thank you well we
actually got some details that came out
about the Disney Plus series centered
around Loki which is pretty exciting yes
they've announced the showrunners -
buckle up boys and girls who are
listening and watching because their new
showrunner will be Michael Waldron a
Rick and Morty rider who also worked on
community and Harmon quest and The
Hollywood Reporter dropped at this
little quote sources say the show will
follow Loki as the trickster and
shapeshifter pops up throughout human
history as unlikely as an unlikely
influencer on historical events that
sounds pretty dang sweet so I don't know
we're gonna get some time-traveling
adventures on a Loki killing sheep shift
and who knows it sounds like a very high
concept and cool but like there's a lot
of questions what do you guys think
initially from this from this well
that's interesting so he's the god of
mischief right so it's just like kind of
going back and explaining like what's he
Hindenburg explosion it sounds awesome
and it doesn't have to be time-travel
like even though time travel probably
maybe be introduced an end game it could
be like he was just there well it makes
it makes sense yeah you're right he's
always been there yeah and I know I've
heard rumors that he's actually maybe
just gonna narrate it and they might not
they might have a different actor play
like a younger version of I'm just a
rumor but it would make a lot of sense
that it also explains the character is
currently dead
again we don't know if time travel could
undo that but even if it's not undone if
it's a retrospective in his dying
moments he's having these thoughts yeah
something about these memories and
that's the show that's really cool but I
actually really kind of think it'd be
fun if they do the whole like revisit
history even though it's like a little
cheesy to see people play like you know
how many times are we seeing different
actors play Hitler or something Einstein
yeah so a version of Einstein or
something I you know they do it on CW
weekly but
but I think that if they do it with
stuff that's like maybe just a little
less known a little less cheesy like
even though this is still insanely huge
I'm probably gonna butcher this story
but I'm remembering the so Archduke
Ferdinand assassination
leads to World War one and if I remember
correctly he the assassin failed and was
was not able to kill him and then for
some reason the Archduke was like I
think like oh man I almost got killed
I'm just gonna hop into this pub and and
get a drink about the nd assassin was
there and killed him there oh right so
it'sit's we see the alternate versions
like hey you want to come in for a drink
you know he's quirky stories you know
what it sounds like it totally sounds
like quantum leap right evil quantum
leap Scott yeah Scott Bakula going back
in like to these famous historical
moments but like by playing the person
he sets the timeline back to the way it
should be historically it's not like
he's altering timeline events just again
making them bad and looking personally I
may be poor as Dizz as did me put on
disney hat for a second and being like
baby don't have the character that's
bankable like setting up murders have
started like world wars it's interesting
but a big popular thing happening right
now in Thor comics is flashing back to
when he was a young boy and who's
playing around on earth with like the
Vikings and whatnot and you're seeing
him fight monsters and you're seeing him
like having to stop threats so seeing
Loki possibly getting into trouble with
other Norse monsters from legend and
whatnot that could be pretty interesting
as well because I feel like they still
are trying to pivot him towards being
like okay because he's still part of
like Thor's team of good guys prior to
Thor 1 I think it should kind of bridge
the gap it'd be fun if he was like an
antihero figure each time he wants to
serve his own selfish needs or his
desires maybe each time he ends up
actually the way to do it is a lighter
version of Dexter where essentially he's
not getting someone killed but it's or
killing them it's more someone gets
their comeuppance and he cause injury
right he helps a serial killer get
caught or he wold in like help a serial
killer
yeah you know he gets Nixon taken down
or something but it's a it's like
through mischiefs yeah I like your
thought Phillip on less obvious less
famous historical events because you're
right we've seen you know the Lincoln
assassination we've seen Hitler in the
bunker like these kind of things we know
but if it's like yeah the XYZ affair
insulted the new American Republic and
it caused some major trade problems or
yeah who is the spy in World War two
she's female she's French and she was
like known as like one of like the
biggest she kind of use her sexuality to
kind of get secrets over to the Allies
we don't know her name and this is why
this needs to be closed but in the
comics there's a very popular run where
Loki's a woman and that could be kind of
fun where you can have like kind of like
some gender-bending and whatnot also
that sounds like a season there you go
but also it's worth asking do you think
anyone gonna be time-traveling with Loki
or time-traveling but going along with
his adventure because he already we know
at at least these point before for one
he does have friends yeah just as guard
and exactly go introduce another
Asgardian that is also ancient and can
do it too instead of having having to
take like a reporter with him and she's
like what's happening I mean this sounds
like a great like that pitch yeah
hundred episodes already set up right
here it sounds like a great concept for
a show like we know Captain America was
around in the 40s maybe there could be
some episode where he's dancing around
the events of World War two and in
working with Hydra heard things like
that I mean it legitimately quantum leap
was at its best it maybe not best it's
the favorite episodes about quantum leap
if you haven't seen it or adjacent
history right so he does have the
opportunity for instance in an episode
to prevent JFK's assassination but
realizes that that's actually not what
he should do that that actually in some
ways was led to good things too but
immediately after like Vietnam becomes
terrible because of it and he transports
there and it's no longer about like oh
Vietnam it's his own brother is there
and his brother's gonna get killed and
so it becomes a personal story in the
context of Vietnam rather than like can
he prevent Vietnam can he prevent it we
are talking about some pretty high
stakes storylines how do you think they
can keep the stake
going throughout this show since we
already know where he's gonna end up is
it more about the situation because it's
like we do know how those situations end
up as well or does it come back to
possibly his supporting cast being
someone that he cares about and that's
what it's I mean that's what it's got to
be right it's got to be low-key jr. yeah
like his child or something like you
have to do it in character development
and relationships right because if they
can go back to these historical moments
and introduce lesser-known figures
people whose names we don't know they
can fictionalize them and make them up
and we're worried about whether that
person's gonna survive in history
because we care about them so much so
maybe rather than like one episode at a
time because yeah if you know it's gonna
be solved in an hour you might not care
as much but if you can introduce
characters over the course of a season
and you're worried that this character
may not survive or maybe we can spend
three or four episodes and one
historical then get to know and love
certain characters yeah then we were
worried about their fates and that's
actually something Sam that kind of
addresses your issue so low-key one will
not feel a disposal II won't feel like
it like he could be killed but everyone
else that he interacts with that is not
famous could die that episode or in 50
episodes you know I mean like if he has
a love interest for instance she could
die at the end of the episode or she
could die at the end of the series yeah
it's almost like Doctor Who or even like
Doctor Strange like we're not so much
worried about the fate of the hero
because he's almost like outside of time
and already escaped death we're worried
about the people he's trying to protect
you know and then if you can build some
stakes around that this could be a
really great show I'm very excited to
see possibly like a Victorian England
episode iam I'm feeling this a deeper
kind of him taking out all the serial
killers throughout history yeah zodiac
maybe I'm listening to a podcast right
now on that know what historical events
you've mentioned a few would you want
Loki to influence or have influence on
in the Marvel Universe because also it's
like Black Panther it had us like
realized I guess slavery did happen the
United States and glory things have
happened so like you mentioned like
World War Two and slike yeah we knew
that happen but it's also like we could
disconnect because it's Hydra you know
it's like it's not the same it's not the
same thing when you start mentioning
like other stuff like that it's like oh
yeah I like assassination attempts
happened and stuff yes
killers I think is a smart way to go
there's so many dark ways to go with
that Oh me Cuban Missile Crisis sounds
like ripe for first-class Bay of Pigs
just like because that went super poorly
and you know could be the reason why
yeah I mean we've seen so much of 20th
century history fictionalized or you
know documentary fiction style in a
different like sci-fi and fantasy I'd
love to see like you know restoration
England and the Civil War so there's so
much backstabbing it's what like Game of
Thrones it's based on so much and almost
like political intrigue the War of the
Roses I'd love to see like a
revisitation of that but it's not gonna
happen the whole thing takes place only
post 2006 he watched one six references
you do such a good job on Broadway for
sure yeah 100% Loki would be great on
Hamilton and going back to the American
Revolution
yeah that's what we want to see well let
us know what you want to see from this
do you like this idea do you want to see
any particular historical event let us
know in the comments below but we had
some other news that came out this week
I want to get to you guys so we got
another update about the future of the
Star Wars trilogy a couple updates but
we know now that the producers of Game
of Thrones spinning off and Weiss are
making a whole trilogy of Star Wars
movies so potentially to take over since
the saga is essentially alright yeah
interesting yeah so they also look like
the chainsmokers because I don't know
what the chainsmokers look like no one
knows what the chainsmokers yes the we
also found out that Jared Leto's time as
the Joker is most likely over with the
Suicide Squad sequel being more of a
reboot that's the one that James done
James Gunn is doing I know also there
were plans of a Jared Leto Joker solo
movie and news of a Jared Leto Joker
Margot Robbie Harley Quinn story there
was going to be The Crazy Stupid Love
directors or writers we're going to
produce that one that
around conversion both those have been
scrapped good call so there's really no
future project with Jared Leto playing
the Joker so if you weren't fans of that
then good news I mean I wonder what
changed right because I mean we were
we've been saying it you know it sounds
like the whole you know the guy running
the DC stuff at Warner Brothers the head
of Ken whatever is kind of rethinking
the whole future that he's seen I think
he's waiting to see how well Shazam does
there's some of these properties like
Aquaman was obviously a huge success for
them a Wonder Woman 2 will probably be
well but the Batman's not coming till
2021 and any future plans for team-up
movies have kind of been dialed back
yeah honestly maybe it's trying to cut
the roots that have been established and
like be like have a soft reboot and it's
like we can't keep showing the old stuff
yeah and and there's gonna be playing
Morbius it sounds like in other news we
also got some details regarding a
Breaking Bad movie at AMC it'll be a
sequel to the series it's gonna start
Aaron Paul's character Jesse and he's
going we're gonna see where he goes
after he drives off in a red car they
also it's premiering on Netflix
oh that's also on that place yeah will
his red Camaro tie into the walking dead
since that's what GLAAD drives and
there's blue meth exist in the universe
probably not but then we also got some
other Star Wars news there was a website
super movie Bros they reported initially
at Rian Johnson was no longer working on
its previously an out Star Wars trilogy
but then Rian Johnson debunk this on
Twitter he said quote no it isn't true
I'm still working on the trilogy with
all due respect to the movie Bros who
I'm sure our lovely kind Bros with good
fraternal intentions then they posted a
statement where they fully apologized
and and then Johnson was like oh no I'm
I love Johnson's other response after
that where he's like basically gave the
fist bump thing he's like no it's good I
know fan speculation and rumors make the
whole thing more fun and I think we
better go foot-in-mouth a couple times
with our theories with our speculation
so it's nice to know that the filmmakers
support this kind of fandom even when
it's sometimes cast them in a negative
light because I think that's what's
going on there
and then finally we got some news from
Hulu its who is getting deeper into the
Marvel business now they already have
the show runaways you know Marvel show
about the teenage children is super
villains but they recently announced
four new animated shows including the
Howard the Duck series written and
produced by Kevin Smith where some of
the other one oh there's there's
technically four other ones ones like a
little TV movie or miniseries we're
getting Howard the Duck we're getting
hit monkey hit manage monkey it's gonna
be like a new art style series it's
animated in Japan pretty cool
Tigra and Dazzler as a team-up series
from Chelsea Handler and you're getting
mowed off from Patton Oswalt and K yeah
you said Kevin Smith's producing oh yeah
Patton I was looking no I he's producing
right now and it will lead to a team-up
series called the offender's who are
gonna save earth and certain parts of
the universe according to The Hollywood
Reporter it's always got to lead to a
team of things right defenders or
Avengers everything yeah
big fan really excited yep so that
covers all of our news but now it's time
for it's called the debrief now
lightning round guys tweeted us
questions and I'm going to fire them at
my co-host I'll have to answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible wait what or they're killed
cool down yep let's do it alright cloudy
one and only what an unexpected couple
do you think will come together in the
last season of Game of Thrones ooh
Arianna girl I think I think they're
just oh that be going that way yeah Erik
like Daisy's best love scene of all the
DC and Marvel movies oh this love scene
the only ones coming to mind is when
quill and Gamora kissed and volume 2
right yeah didn't they kiss so they got
close to kissing weird one with close
dad and his mom in the whole world
Black Widow doing the palm Suns getting
real low pretty oh thank you x-rated for
me Sam Cappy kid who was your first
comic book crush Oh star fibro get that
in Star
at sensei I am if Bruce Wayne was
introduced to the women of marble who
would he fall in love with the most
pristine doesn't fall in love with me if
anything it'd be a villain who was like
good at the same time black cat hmm no
that's cheating
yep yeah all right everybody Eric all
the women would be on him at Andrea
Clark 92 what does Santos look for in
his ideal romantic partner being
mistress death would be rare yeah I
already been Jenna be mr. little yes
yeah we do learned last week Thanos
means mistress at jean-noel Oh what's
the weirdest romantic storyline you've
ever read in comics Oh No
right now Robins dating a 3000 year old
genie that looks like a 13 year old girl
and we have to pretend that that's okay
that's a lot better than the other ones
you could have said I know yeah the
Marvel's been through the wringer and
people have been mean to it yeah and
people keeping the family and others
anyway Claudia one and only do you think
ray Lowe will happen in Star Wars
Episode nine this is my if you guys
don't know this is a character I meant
to name ray Lowe who is a fun janitor
who just cleans up after the droids I
think I'll find a way to get him in
there Oh ray Loewy unless you mean you
know brancai which I don't think so
Erekat wowza HP do you think they are
going to give Captain Marvel love
interest in her film no I don't I don't
think it's gonna be about that and
shouldn't be yeah not interested
yeah who cares who wants one this for
everybody at fraud ham this is a very
kind way to say this snog marry avoid
Cersei Sansa Olenna snug fancy avoid two
of those turfs or not once we use
regularly
no one said fancy your answer
I'll snog fancy oh yeah snog marry or
avoid
or avoid she's the hot one Mary you'll
marry Sansa make theirs marry Sansa
uh-huh oh it is snog and kill avoid kill
it's made up name let's see I would
marry Elena
it seemed that she's like she cares
about like the family bloodline and puts
family values first and she protects her
own avoid Cersei and kind of avoid
Cersei and then snog Sansa that seems
like an easy one nothing I don't agree
yeah I know I would marry Olynyk because
she's funny and that's important to me
over time but then you know she doesn't
have that much time left and I inherit
half of her wealth snog well avoid Sansa
honestly cuz like whiny snog Cersei cuz
she crazy but she's not you're not her
type I gotta be honest she's gotta be a
tight he has one wife yeah one time and
that can be Phillip honestly it looks a
lot more like Erik was a lightning rod
marvel of interest right I just
completely blank but it's implied that
maybe she and Peter quill used to date
there's that joking guardians that we
found that maybe they're they hooked up
at one point I don't know that if we did
see a love story it only be with Peter
girl there's only one okay well she also
dated Warmachine in the comics that
could work too hey girl
well thank you for sending us all those
questions time thank you guys my
favorite show buckle up cause this is
when each of us has 15 seconds to shout
out plug or bamboo a ramble anything
that they want Sam why don't you start
I'd love to first off I'd like to say
shout out to Darren Gardner's an artist
friend and roommate of mine who just
dropped an EP called Lemon Grove if you
like fun tunes and hip-hopping you can
go ahead and listen to that also I do a
show called only stupid answers now
let's go to Eric OH
on March 1st will be round 2 of darkest
timeline comedy at the Acme theatre in
North Hollywood we're having some
special guests Phillip will be coming
back we have some other friends that I
know from the Second City and used to be
in Groundlings it's gonna be super super
funny super super nerdy see their time
at Philip okay earlier we were talking
about quantum leap there's an episode
where he goes back and he hangs out with
his little sister and I like the fifties
there's a minute and he plays for her
imagine and he takes credit for that
song and now there's a movie that's
coming out like that called yesterday
it's got a really delightful trailer yes
watch that trailer damn movie's gonna be
really fun I'm very excited for that
trailer but yes now it's a another fun
point in the show where we get to get
the answer to the trivia question and
Sam usually wins Erik oh yeah okay the
question we asked earlier the loser as
always will have to pull from our broken
gift machine bucket broke that Sam just
to remind everyone of what the question
was which comic book superhero was
originally created by a major toy
company so let's see what we said oh
well first up with Erik who wrote Erik
cable hero Erik on both ends so he
didn't lose any point people have to
flip over yep
ten points off if you don't say it put
your name on it Philip said Plastic Man
which is his oh yeah just the Plastic
Man in small subtitle he wrote or he-man
by the way plastic man's a wonderful
penmanship you have a wonderful oh thank
you thank you I've been practicing my
Plastic Man signature for a long time
and Sam wrote Dazzler I didn't look
behind to see Busey GE the correct
answer is he-man
[Music]
second answer is correct I didn't I feel
like all comic book characters made for
toy to be fair you Dantzler was made by
marvel and a record company teaming up
to create a pop star put that out there
yeah okay so judges our winner this week
he didn't say great cuz it's super hero
if she's just saying who who is close or
like that's not very close sam hasn't
lost in a while what are you kidding me
I lost almost every episode I've been
back okay so Phillips winner who's our
loser okay okay so I broke the gift of
shame box I didn't do that
so our judges have decided that Phillip
is our winner and did write theme a nice
car to be fair Sam our decided furthest
away
so Sam's going to draw from our gift of
shame box and careful this time his
stupidity as he does this activity will
be turned into an animated gif if you're
listening to us on the podcast
check out our Twitter page at new rock
stars to figure out what the heck we're
talking and use that gift as you like it
and using it all right you guys give me
suggestions for this one I have show us
what quote extra looks like be extra I
don't think this is gonna be hard for
using extra looks like alright I'll fair
warning I pounded a full burrito before
I got here and it is not digested fully
so I'm gonna be slow let's get going I
don't know how the burritos gonna come
into play it is but I'm concerned all
right guys it's been a really nice week
hanging out with you guys and my friends
here apparently Eric has other friends
he mentioned earlier thank you guys for
watching or listening to this week's
episode of new rock stars debrief I want
to thank our other hosts Sam basher at
Sam basher Eric glass
Garret come home soon and me at fimo
what do you have what is this
it's ci hitting me on all senses is what
it is
you're screaming also why's this
becoming snagglepuss video form III
wanna end Sam skip of shame why doesn't
it hold up that of the road wearing NASA
shirts
screaming youtube.com slash the
rockstars if you want to see the video
you get the audio anywhere you get
podcasts but please get them the
himalaya app because they support the
actual podcast you're watching you can
leave comments on there directly by the
way comment and tweet at us at new
rockstars most places account like this
video or the podcast share it around
subscribe to new rock stars for the deep
dives into the stuff you love I will see
you next week Sam you got one more sound
it's a baby burrito put that on your
sound board and play that when
appropriate baby brother it's a baby
burrito